so there is a reality that we now have
to deal with which is that Bernie
Sanders has lost as in the process of
losing the Democratic primary de facto
not officially but he has lost there's
no path to the nomination we looked at
all of the math already today so now the
progressive left is going to have an
important decision to make this is not a
trivial matter this is really a matter
that could determine who is the next
president of the United States does
Donald Trump get another four years as
president of the United States and
fundamentally the question is do you
want to remove Trump enough that you
will vote for Joe Biden or do you have
other priorities that you will do
something else you will not vote you
will write someone in you'll maybe vote
for Trump in November all of which will
either directly or by default help get
Donald Trump re-elected in November now
to be very clear I have no illusion that
Biden is certain to beat Donald Trump in
November it's going to be a turnout
battle and specifically it'll be turnout
in key states which will decide who wins
it will be the economy if the economy is
generally perceived to be good in
October or November it will be difficult
to knock out an incumbent president if
the economy is considered to be bad as
we get closer to November then it will
be easier to remove an incumbent
president so this is sort of bigger than
the specific candidates and last night I
had a ton of people tweeting at me
furiously when I said here's why I will
vote for Biden Oh Biden over Trump that
they are not going to vote for Joe Biden
Biden is well to my right but I am going
to vote for Joe Biden over Donald Trump
now I'm not going to get if people are
wondering what are we in for here
between now and November I'm not going
to get angry at anyone I'm not gonna
yell I'm not gonna call anybody stupid
if they are going to do something
different than what I'm going to do if
Trump gets reelected I will deal with it
what what am I gonna do I can only do
what I can do but I do want to make it
clear that you will be helping to
re-elect Donald Trump and some people
want to do that it is a strategy for
some on the Left to say listen I'm sick
of this
I'm sick of this centrist stuff if it's
not Bernie I would rather it be Trump
maybe to teach a lesson to the Democrats
maybe to burn it down and start all over
in 2024 we simply disagree I'm not going
to attack anyone here's my view as I
tweeted it last night I said there's no
doubt Biden isn't a progressive but I
want him and not Trump choosing Ruth
Bader Ginsburg's replacement his climate
plan is better than Trump's and his
health care plan is milquetoast but it's
better than what Trump wants to do if
there's little else to say in my mind
it's actually not even just the Supreme
Court it's all sorts of judges these
judges are often lifetime appointments
Ruth Bader Ginsburg's 86 years old if
Trump gets reelected will she stay on
the court until 2025 when she will be 91
when the next president is sworn in
that's risky
I don't want Trump choosing her
replacement Joe Biden would choose a
better replacement for RBG then whoever
Donald Trump would choose whoever
replaces Ginsburg is going to make
decisions on that court for decades
decisions that will impact people my age
for the rest of our lives
decisions that will impact for a lot of
the rest of my life decisions that will
impact my kids for the rest of for a lot
of their lives
it's even conceivable that the person
Trump picks to replace RBG will impact
the lives of the grandchildren of people
that are currently my age depending on
how young they are
I don't want Trump getting that much
power for me teaching the DNC a lesson
and remember 70% of the votes so far
have been for people other than Bernie
that doesn't make me say let's give
Trump another supreme court pick which
will make it a seven to two Supreme
Court this applies to federal and
appellate judges as well number two the
environment Donald Trump is destroying
the environment he got us out of the
Paris climate Accords
he's reducing efficiency standards for
vehicles pollution standards every
single day that Trump doesn't fix it is
time lost where we should have been
fixing it and it will be harder to fix
it once Trump is
finally gone for me that's bigger than
politics Biden would put us back in the
Paris climate Accords but more
importantly on his website Biden says
he's in favor of the green new deal now
whatever you think about the feasibility
of the green new deal if you're somebody
who thinks there's no chance in hell we
pass the green New Deal well that's the
same under Bernie if your view is we
need a president who's for the green New
Deal Biden is that's better than Trump
and then number three even on health
care Bernie wants Medicare for all Biden
wants this milquetoast thing of expand
Obama care Medicare Medicaid add a
public option it's not as good as what
Bernie wants but Trump wants a
disastrous for-profit implosion that
will lead to 20 to 30 million more
people losing health care is Biden's
plan the most exciting plan no is it
what I would like to see no does it do
enough no is it obviously better than
Trump's and the answer is yes and so for
me this is a question of my ethics and
morality if I know that if I react if I
take an action which will help reelect
Trump I'm hurting the planet how can I
do that in good faith that it's the
planet is worse off if Trump is
re-elected if I do anything that will
help Trump get reelected our Supreme
Court and other courts will be
controlled by lunatic ideologues for
decades it's immoral for me to take an
action that will make that more likely
if I see well Biden's health care plan
isn't that great but it will expand
access somewhat Trump will reduce access
if these are the options it would be
immoral for me to make a vote or not
make a vote there it's the same thing
that will make more likely that Donald
Trump gets to put put 20 or 30 more
million people out of health care so I'm
not gonna do it okay that's what I think
about when I think about what to do in
November now if you have a different
approach that's fine we just disagree
I'm not mad at you I don't think you're
necessarily a bad person I just think
you're wrong
what I would encourage you to think
about is when has burn it all down
worked in sort of the modern historical
era when you look at the progressive
reforms of the nine 1890s through the
1920s it did
come from burn it all down it came from
we deal with industrialization we deal
with immigration in reasonable ways we
regulate monopolies we regulate
corporations we get more women working
outside of the home we help labor unions
grow we get women the right to vote that
was the 1890s to the 1920s nothing was
burned down and it was a big step
forward the New Deal era the first and
second New Deal's under FDR in the mid
twentieth century it was not burn it
down it was elect a more socially
Democratic president and get things done
public works financial reform banking
reform monetary reform housing stimulus
labor relations the Social Security Act
I can keep listing this was not burn it
all down this was elect someone further
to the left of where we were and do
everything you can to actually get
things passed and make things happen
last example the civil rights era of the
1960's tons of protesting and public
actions which I support and we need more
of it was not a burn it down scenario to
make progress and there's no doubt that
progress was made so this is my view
like me or hate me for it I'm being an
adult with you I'm telling you what I
see and why I plan to do what I'm going
to do I don't want to assist Donald
Trump and getting reelected change my
mind I am more than open to reasonable
discussions I am we are not going to
tolerate and everybody on staff and
moderators on all of our everybody knows
when the anti-semitic attacks against me
saying this is my view because I'm a
Zionist shill appear come on guys get
seriously give there's too much going on
to be doing that we're not going to
tolerate any of that stuff reasonable
discussion and debate that's what we
want and I know I'll be hearing from you
guys on live calls and more coming up
one of our sponsors today is VIN Chara
watches giving you 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch don't pay thousands of
dollars for a high-quality watch that
looks great because you don't have to
all event arrows watches are made with
high-end materials masterfully built and
they look like something you'd spend a
ton of money on but every venture oh wow
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether
and silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a cronograph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people asked me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get 15%
off inch arrows entire collection when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch